and this is a Fox News Alert The
Associated Press projecting that Roy
Moore will win the Alabama Senate runoff
as we continue with the author of the
best-selling book killing England the
brutal struggle for American
independence Bill O'Reilly is with us I
say that's a referendum on McConnell
yeah
the folks are mad they want very
conservative
elected officials more very famous in
Alabama I knew he was going to win from
the jump sort of uh and I don't know
whether that's a good or a bad thing
we'll see how he performs I want to ask
you about the media I have never seen
any institution in America that is so
corrupt so bitterly ideological so
one-sided that never talked about you
always said the folks I talk about the
Forgotten men and women people that came
from our background or worse yeah they
never talk about them all they want to
do is destroy this president 24/7 365
conspiracy theories I love in the human
I think about you do they want to
destroy President Trump but anyone who
voted for him
anyone supports him on air or gives them
a fair shot
it just goes across the board look we're
living in a time where there are no more
journalistic rules and I can back that
up 50 different ways but I'm not going
to bore everybody tonight but I will
someday there are no rules anymore so
your major urban newspapers aren't
newspapers their left-wing journals and
they coordinate and the people on the
cable news shows on the other channels
their left-wing top to bottom if you
wear and make America great hat into the
New York Times tomorrow and you work
there you're not gonna be working there
much longer all right it's very very
intense very intense but what's happened
now is big money is poured in to
organizations like Media Matters do you
know they threaten you and me if we did
this segment tonight oh they do matters
they threatened me was just having
allowing you to have a voice just to
have the segment that's that was that
we're threatened yes okay because these
totalitarians
want to wipe out any speech with which
they disagree see I call them liberal
because that's a good the most tolerant
people as it comes to speak we defend
Bill Maher I hate Bill Maher I never I
never know the real bill oh you do you
your buddies or them I can't stand I did
I never said that Kathy Griffin should
be fired or anybody that no no I don't
care what they say and you don't call
for boycotts you turn the dial yeah
there isn't a right wing cabal that does
that no I mean the right can get hateful
everybody knows that I mean they can but
there's not an organization that goes
out and threatens people and and and
boycott sponsors now here's the
insidious part that's bad enough all
right
there's millions of dollars behind that
and those people who are doing it are
being paid to do it
big money wait wait no go ahead cheryl
atkinson great cheryl Atkinson's book
smear you've got to read it this is a
brilliant woman an honest reporter used
to work at CBS the book is smear it'll
document a twosie this big money and
these people will do anything bill every
minute of every day that we have rush on
later this week every prominent
conservative voice is recorded they're
paid to record they're paid to to
transcribe they're paid to look for the
one word sentence phrase that they can
then use to attack either advertisers or
others advertisers that's not it's works
let's be honestly it has worked in the
past hannity and i have discussed this
off-camera and we're gonna fight back
and you i have to give you all the
credit in the world you fought back when
they came after you last spring I didn't
and I should have but anyway this is so
dangerous to the country people don't
know how dangerous this is because most
people aren't engaged they don't pay
attention they just hear things and
these propaganda people throw this stuff
out as fact when it just lies across the
board let me move on let me ask you your
I think the president has done a great
job in terms of doing everything that he
promised that he's able to do
on his own I've never seen more impotent
people more ineffective people people
that can't keep simple promises like
repealing and replacing and getting it
done you talk about the folks it's
hurting the Forgotten men and women that
certainly never find this election
certainly in Arizona is not about I was
very surprised John McCain and I respect
John became known for a long time I have
a video of him
I can play everybody knows that he had
it but I think it was personal I think
they did it angered him and look you
can't blame they came for that what
Trump said about McCain was out of line
I said it on a factor I told Trump to
his face out of line okay but sometime
down the road if you John McCain you got
to say what's the greater good
what's the greater good to help my
people in Arizona who are paying far too
much for their health insurance or to
stick it to a guy why do people want to
not only defeat the president
politically they want to destroy him and
deal it I'm holding an effing to jump I
had the first interview when he declared
and I said they're gonna come after you
because what Trump does is that he goes
right to the people you don't need the
big media Trump and that's what he's
doing with the NFL Trump's going right
to the people and he knows and I think
he's right that most people are agreeing
with him he's gonna win that all right
so he goes around the media it's the
worst thing you can do to the media the
media in many ways is dying before our
very eyes I don't think they recover
from the abuse of by it if you heard the
conspiracy theories it is the most
bizarre Russia Russia Russia Russia Bill
24/7 again to hurt the president in the
process it's not only the president that
gets hurt
it's nothing gets done for the couple
where do you see what happens when Paul
Manafort gets indicted the other thing
which i think is gonna I think it's
gonna happen sadly I think you're right
in the sense that fair-minded people not
conservatives and liberals because there
are liberals who are very good and very
fair all right but fair-minded people
know there's no objectivity in the media
anymore name name the fair name five
Fair Republic rhotic senators and
congressmen was there one that's will in
a mansion
a fair guy in West Virginia what does
mansion he's not reaching out with
President Trump on the health care all
right you want you want to know why the
Schumer won't let him well that's right
Senator Schumer from New York has told
all of the Democratic senators two
things unless you vote straight
party-line with us we will run someone
against you in a primary and we will cut
off all your money so that you will not
have money from the DNC to campaign
every senator has gotten that message
all right so on close calls they're
gonna go with Schumer now I think on the
tax cuts they might get sums will then
proceed three or four Democrats three or
four but if you're gonna have three or
four Republicans say no I guarantee you
Susan Collins in Maine I guarantee
should be a Democrat
how about we work for the people public
servants anymore bill they're not
serving the public serving themselves
but that's nothing new it well not this
bad I have never seen the vitriol and
look we started out started on this
channel 23 years ago it's never been
this bad ever I got to tell you in the
20 years six months I worked for FNC I
was attacked every single day of my life
every day by the way must say
bull's-eyed the two Irish guys yeah all
right uh we got to take a break I want
to talk about this something I want to
go back to your book when you talk about
institutions today there's a lot of
parallels to what you're writing about
that I think we can learn from yeah
Dallas did the Dallas horns Lord I want
to get into the Fed into that or